I want to start with congratulations on
the movie thought you guys both did a
great job uh I have an individual
question for each of you to start things
off Billy I'm going to start with you uh
what do I need to do to see your
director's cut of All the Pretty Horses
uh well let's see I I don't know that
that will ever happen but I wish it
would
uh there's uh a possibility now that the
lugard is in in a position that might
allow us to do that
so it's something I've always thought
about so that's really a possibility and
if you heard the original score by
Daniel lenwa it's pretty spectacular I
very much would like it to happen please
let me know how I can help okay and I'm
being completely sincere with you sure
um an individual question for you um so
you've worked with Tarantino the Russo
brothers and now Steven Spielberg have
you thought about playing the lottery or
doing something like you know what I
mean because it's incredible thank you
so much yeah I don't even think that's
real at all like sometimes I just don't
even understand what's going on but um I
would love to do a biopic or like an odd
jerk playing Audrey Hepburn
um that kind of thing I would love to do
that I hope that's something that'll
happen in the future but working with
the Russo Brothers was such an
incredible experience because not only
because there's two of them but because
um
they feed off of each other's energy in
a way that I've never seen before where
they kind of I expected them as brothers
to kind of you know no I disagree I
wanted it to be like this but no they
are exactly the same but so different I
don't even know if that makes any sense
but really it's incredible watching them
work and the one will have an idea and
one will go tell it one that one that
just told it will have an idea and it's
it's really incredible the way that
their minds work together to create
something so beautiful uh Ryan Gosling
basically fights everyone in this movie
but the two of you
um and I'm just curious we were a little
disappointed during the shoot that you
didn't have a fight sequence with Ryan
well I had a I had some verbal sparring
with him I'm teasing about that but
um one of the things I love learning
about like the behind the scenes of the
making of movies
um for each of you what do you think
soon to be fans of the gray man would be
surprised to learn about the actual
making of the movie hmm what do you
think
well I think uh
since it was so intense and there was so
much action and there was a it was a you
know a big movie with a lot of moving
parts
uh I think the
the mood among the crew and the cast
everywhere we shot from Long Beach to
France to Prague everywhere
was very relaxed you know I think that's
one thing that uh that might surprise
people that you would think this set was
just like this chaotic right sort of
thing and it was actually quite the
opposite yeah they were very good about
staying Zen and I remember Joe
specifically telling me like
anything you're worried about not a big
deal we'll fix it just stays in
stays in